hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
for tonight's battle royale is all about
looking good on the battlefield and
following on from the place they should
for skin and glider which was free to
all PS Plus subscribers twitch prime are
getting in on the act so here's
everything you need to know about
getting the new skins a new back fling
new twitch emotes and a glider - and
there's even more for the PvE mode and
of course the word free is a little bit
of a misdirect as it's more of a reward
for Amazon Prime subscribers there's a
30-day free trial you could take
advantage of and download this precious
loot for nothing
skip - this time in the video if you
know all about twitch prime already if
you don't I'd recommend sticking around
for a minute and I'll break down
everything you need to know about that
word free which always scares me I'm
sure you know twitch as a streaming
platform for content creators well it's
actually owned by Amazon Amazon push out
a service called Amazon Prime which
includes video streaming to your TV next
day delivery on products and access to
music books that well the list is
plentiful this service costs real money
every single month in the UK I pay $7.99
a month but this suits me mainly because
the discounts around Christmas time help
me recoup that money back in but
everyone is different
twitch Prime is a part of Amazon Prime
and allows users to sub to a channel
each month to skip those horrendous
in-stream ad verse on top of this there
is a frying loot aspect which regularly
offers in-game upgrades and items from
many different video games Call of Duty
warframe paladin's the games change each
month and sometimes each week I'm not
here to recommend it or warn you away
but I think it's important to have a
quick overview anyway let's try and get
that twitch prime loot bar 3 here we go
to get the twitch prime fortnight gear
without spending a penny you'll need to
take advantage of the Amazon Prime trial
over on the main Amazon page there is a
trial button usually in the top corner
if not Google Amazon Prime trial if you
have any issues next it's a case of
signing up for the service which will
require a credit card this is here to
prevent people from taking advantage of
the system
which were trying to do now and here's
the scary part if you don't cancel
before the 30 days ends you will be
charged each month to
continue the service so if you really
want this for free you'll need to sign
up download the gear and then cancel
your subscription immediately once
that's up and running go to twitch TV
and sign in or sign up next you'll need
to link your Amazon Prime and twitch
accounts this should be automated but if
it isn't go to settings and connections
once complete the lute crown in the top
right hand corner will become active
click here regularly to see all the
games and extras you can download find
for tonight and claim the offer we're
almost there but we're not done yet next
you'll need to go over to epic games
calm and link your account in the top
right hand corner there's a little head
and shoulders icon click on this and
link your PC ps4 or Xbox accounts next
click the have twitch Prime button and
confirm and authorize your account oh we
did it
there you go bitter the fast but the
next time you jump into battle royale
the skins will be waiting for you and if
you ever play the PvE molt there's some
extras in there too oh I think I may
have found my new favourite skin I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade and a
quick disclaimer I am not sponsored by
twitch I am not sponsored by Amazon I am
not sponsored by anyone it's just me in
a room all by myself I bought it from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
you